ici on a vraiment une toile qui
représente bien les peuples absolument
décidément montréal n'a pas été que
l'épicentre de lakovic 19 c'est la seule
représentation d'un hôpital en nouvelle
france
des épidémies la métropole on a connu
comme en témoigne l'exposition dans ce
musée également aux cinq ans mais c'est
surtout 3,4 maladie variole un choléra
typhus et 20e siècles influence et
statistiques de l'hôtel dieu en première
ligne face aux épidémies il y à la
petite congrégation montréalaise des
soeurs hospitalières qui soigne et
comptabilise les morts et a pas la
science for this à ces attaques véreuses
donc c'est les soins d'hygiène et les
larves et de surtout de les rafraîchir
puis de plans de la médication elle
s'était plainte accuse m'en donner leur
vie pour soigner ma l'air donc ici c'est
une salle où on trouve un des premiers
artfact assez intéressant l'hôtel dieu
de montréal a été aux premières loges
des nombreuses épidémies qui ont frappé
le québec et les masques étaient presque
absents on a entre autres un masque qui
a été porté dans les années 1930 par une
infirmière portes noir ce qui était
réservé aux chirurgie pour des
opérations chirurgicales est beaucoup
utilisé pour mettre les terres ou le
chloroforme pour endormir les patients
william hingston ancien maire de
montréal est par ailleurs chirurgien a
vécu ces situations ironie ce qu'il a
accepté un des premiers patients
atteints de la variole donc l'épidémie
de 1885 est partie de l'hôtel dieu de
montréal décennie après décennie ces
nombreuses épidémies et est souvent
causée par une immigration massive et
une hygiène insuffisante
c'est des conditions sanitaires
épouvantable morial à un des plus hauts
taux de mortalité au monde
montréal
toutes les villes industrielles un
enfant sur trois meurent avant l'âge
d'un an
pourtant dans ces contextes les
canadiens français qui étaient
réfractaires à la vaccination sont parmi
les victimes les plus touchés en 1885
nos vaccins à l'époque et pas acceptée
socialement et une partie de la
population montréalaise très importante
ne crois pas aux vaccins les crois même
que c'est dommage pour ce rebut sierre
il y à bien des parallèles à faire avec
les épidémies d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
par exemple la distanciation physique
n'a pas toujours été au rendez vous 1918
ploc
c'est que les toits graal sa de quarante
quatre malades avaient délicate à cause
peut-être les docks sépare alors c'est
le contexte là de transmission c'est
très prochain mais la qualité du
personnel soignant était déjà reconnu le
regard de la population vous avez
hospitalière c'était je pourrais dire un
peu leur sauvant la péter avec les
médecins le passé est garant de l'avenir
dit-on et ce musée nous le rappelle ici
frédéric arnould radio canada montréal